this is the iPad Mini 6 and it's the
best iPad of
2022. now that might sound a little bit
funny or odd because this iPad actually
didn't get released in 2022 in fact it
was released in
2021 but still I believe in this so
strongly that it actually recently
ordered an iPad Mini 6 for my own
personal use at home for various reasons
as I'm gonna get into in this review now
yes we did get three other new iPads
that actually did get released in 2022
but they're honestly all pretty mad we
did get the iPad Air 5 which came out
with the M1 chip but that was the only
major difference and it was kind of
Overkill due to the fact that the
display was still 60 hertz so the M1
power wasn't even really used then we
had the iPad 10 which is actually a
really great redesign but they gimped it
with a the slow USBC Port that still
only supports USB 2.0 transfer speeds as
well as only supporting the original
apple pencil while requiring a dongle to
use it and don't forget the huge price
increase up to 450 dollars and finally
the M2 iPad Pro was also matte because
it was the smallest update Apple has
ever made to an iPad Pro mostly just
swapping out the already Overkill M1
chip for an even more Overkill M2 Chip
but now looking back at the iPad Mini 6
which has been out for over a year
already I personally think that right
now this is the best value iPad you can
buy as long as you're not trying to
replace your laptop and you want to use
it for iPad things and that's the idea
that changed my whole perspective on
reviewing this iPad Mini again after a
full year especially now that you can
easily find it on sale for 20 off on
Amazon or just four hundred dollars
which is actually less than the new iPad
10 while having an even faster a15 chip
so even though it's over a year old it's
honestly gonna have the same or even
more lasting value because Apple usually
discontinues software updates for
products based on the chip generation it
comes with so even as we transition into
the new 2023 year let's get into why I
personally recommend the iPad Mini 6
over all of the other iPads what I've
come to realize over the past year is
that there are two buyers when it comes
to iPads those who want to use it as a
laptop replacement or an artistic device
and then there are those who just want
to use it like a regular tablet for
media consumption and hands down I've
realized that I'm in the basic tablet
user Camp mostly because I already have
a 16 inch MacBook Pro at home with a
huge display for when I need need to
actually use a computer with a keyboard
for productivity research business work
or even watching a movie with those
crazy nice speakers so when I thought of
which iPad would be best in my situation
to fill the gaps there's no other answer
than the iPad Mini 6 for one main reason
this has something that no other iPad
has the size and the portability yes you
can hold this thing in one hand like I
am doing right now and you can't do that
with any other iPad so basically this is
the perfect size for many things like
gaming in your hands it's much easier to
use the touch ID button than the other
larger iPads and of course it is the
perfect size for kids if they want to
watch videos watch cartoons or play
games this is basically the perfect iPad
size ever made I have to argue that now
of course the previous iPad Mini 5 was
also small but it had some issues like
coming with the older design which
wasted space on the front with that home
button while the new one has an edge to
edge display with even bezels all around
making it easier to use in your hands
especially for controls within games the
older one of course came with the old
lightning port and it had speakers on
only one side which was the biggest
annoyance ever and speaking of the
speakers the new stereo speakers on the
mini 6 are excellent and more than
enough for regular content consumption
and gaming and speaking of gaming the
a15 chip provides more than enough
performance to get a perfect 60 FPS
gaming experience and basically any game
out there and don't just take my words
for it Dame Tech on YouTube has tested
the mini 6 extensively and he's shown
multiple times that even in the most
graphically intensive game out there
genshin impact it got an average of
59.1 FPS which is basically perfect if
you account for a slight variation which
all devices have not only that but the
experience is Top Notch because the mini
is the perfect size and weight to hold
in your hands for long periods of time
and you can't say that for the rest of
the larger iPads and on top of that the
controls are so easy to access with your
thumbs because of the thin and even
bezels and don't forget the stereo
speakers on both sides to help complete
the experience now on the other hand if
you're simply using it as a tablet to
browse the web or various apps it's such
a pleasant experience being perfectly
Snappy and smooth and providing just
enough display size for easy readability
now in terms of the actual battery life
of this device it's not the best out
there particularly in terms of the iPad
lineup but it's actually still very
impressive beating out the larger iPad
Air and the 12.9 inch iPad Pro in
various battery life tests that I've
seen on YouTube and I've got to say
getting almost 10 hours of usage out of
this small tablet is honestly very
impressive and then and of course if you
really wanted to you could grab the
second gen apple pencil and use it as an
art or note-taking device unlike the new
iPad 10 which still only supports the
old apple pencil I can't believe they
did that and even if you need to do some
more serious work on it the faster USBC
Port is just fine for transferring
footage or files and you could do some
simple editing on this as well if you'd
like and the awesome thing is that the
a15 chip is still really quick for doing
stuff like that of course not as fast as
the M1 or M2 chips but it's gonna get
the job done if you really need to on
occasion but for everything else the
iPad Mini is just absolutely killer in
terms of using it like a basic tablet it
gives you the most convenient experience
you can get while honestly being the
lowest priced modern and redesigned iPad
you can get right now as long as you can
get it for the 400 current sale price on
Amazon so with that said those are all
of the reasons why I firmly believe that
this iPad Mini 6 is the best iPad you
can buy going into the 2023 new year so
if you agree with me check it out using
the YouTube product tag feature below
and click that Circle above to subscribe
for more videos and reviews like this
one thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]